ruf nach konsequenzen nach den
rechtsextremen vorfällen bei der polizei
in nordrhein westfalen wächst der druck
auch auf innenminister gehackt und
erpresst eine cyber-attacke legte teile
der düsseldorfer uniklinik lahm die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen eines
todesfalls und enttäuschung bei den
bayern-fans das eröffnungsspiel der
fußball bundesliga morgen findet corona
bedingt nun doch ohne zuschauer im
stadion statt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport ein
schillernder familie wie verbreitet ist
rechtsextremismus in der polizei und was
macht die politik dagegen wieder diese
fragen nach dem in nordrhein westfalen
mittlerweile 30 beamte vorläufig vom
dienst suspendiert sind sie sollen über
jahre im chat gruppen aktiv gewesen sein
in denen hitler fotos hakenkreuze und
übelsten rassistischen postings
ausgetauscht wurden solche vorfälle
erschüttern das vertrauen in die polizei
erheblich sagt der chef des
bundeskriminalamts milch tadeusz parade
fasst die reaktionen zusammen
der rechtsextremismus skandal in der
nordrhein westfälischen polizei der
nrw-innenminister informiert den
düsseldorfer landtag und kündigte
maßnahmen an
unter anderem einen sonderbeauftragten
gegen rechtsextremismus
zweitens wird dieser beauftragte und das
ist das wichtigste ein handlungskonzept
entwickelt so frühzeitige erkennung von
rechtsextremisten tendenz subventionen
er soll das tun auch unter hinzuziehung
von außen sachverstand nicht nur allein
mit unseren leuten doch die
rechtsextremen vorfälle in
polizeibehörden häufen sich bundesweit
eine wissenschaftliche studie sollte
deshalb untersuchen auch strukturelle
gründe das problem sind doch der
bundesinnenminister blockierte seehofer
dazu
vor wenigen wochen wir haben kein
strukturelles problem diesbezüglich das
heißt sie bleiben dabei diese studie
wird es mit ihnen nicht gehen jetzt
nicht doch der politische druck wächst
polizei und bundespolitik fordern
konsequenzen
daneben steht natürlich nach wie vor die
forderung dass wir auch die wissenschaft
ran lassen müssen und eine forderung die
wir schon seit einem jahr vor uns fährt
waren wie kommt es eigentlich dass sich
beamtinnen und beamte im dienst
radikalisieren oder kommen sie
vielleicht sogar schon mit einem festen
rechtsextremistischen weltbild in die
sicherheitsbehörden hinein wenn sie sich
bewerben das müssen wir dringend
untersuchen eine wissenschaftliche
aufarbeitung allein reiche aber nicht so
die polizeigewerkschaft
sie fordert zusätzlich anonyme
meldeverfahren und damit missstände
innerhalb der polizei in zukunft
leichter aufgedeckt werden können
selbst die polizei gewerkschaft spricht
von viel zu vielen fällen chuck
unterlamm energy in berlin muss im
münster seehofer dann nicht reagieren
also bisher verweist er immer auf den
bericht des bundesverfassungsschutzes
zur lage bei zum rassismus und
rechtsextremismus bei
sicherheitsbehörden der ende september
vorgestellt werden sollen
der befasst sich allerdings nur mit
bereits erfassten und gemeldeten fällen
und das sind unrealistisch weniger hat
sich kürzlich erst der präsident des
bundesverfassungsschutzes beklagt
außerdem werden davon gar nicht erfasst
verdeckte strukturen und verdeckter
rassismus so wie wir sie jetzt gerade in
dem fall in nordrhein westfalen wieder
gesehen haben und deshalb werden jetzt
auch wieder die stimmen lauter die eine
unabhängige studie fordern die grünen
gehören dazu die fdp hat sich dem
angeschlossen rheinland pfalz hat heute
als bundesland eine eigene studie
angekündigt weil eben der lagebericht
den horst seehofer bisher im blick hat
der sache nicht auf den grund geht und
damit wächst auch der druck auf den
bundes- innenminister weiter
die einschätzung unserer hauptstadt
korrespondent in vielen dank stark
unterlamm energy wie gefährlich hacker
angriffe werden können zeigt sich gerade
an der uniklinik düsseldorf
seit einer woche ist das computersystem
dort lahmgelegt telephone e-mails
zugriff auf patientendaten es ging fast
nichts mehr
seit heute ist klar es waren hacker
jetzt wird wegen eines todesfalls
ermittelt christoph distel berichtet
uniklinik düsseldorf hier ist es am
freitag passiert beziehungsweise nicht
passiert eigentlich hätte die 78 jährige
düsseldorferin schnellstmöglich
repariert werden müssen riss in der
aorta jede minute zählt doch fast die
ganze klinik ist lahmgelegt es ist ja so
dass wir seit dem donnerstag von der
notfallversorgung abgemeldet sind und
deshalb auch der rettungsdienst uns gar
nicht erst an fährt dem team im
krankenwagen bleibt nur eins es muss
weiter bis wuppertal
allerdings lautet dran der transport
rund eine halbe stunde und das war für
die patientin leider zu lange denn
unmittelbar nach eintreffen im
krankenhaus verstarb sie
warum dieses drama die antwort ist
kompliziert und vielleicht besonders
tragisch fest steht dass der
hacker-angriff die düsseldorfer
uniklinik mit ziemlicher wucht traf die
dortigen systeme wurden infiltriert und
teilweise verschlüsselt wir ermitteln
wegen versuchter erpressung und
computersabotage
das alles könnte aber ein
missverständnis gewesen sein denn
eigentlich hatten die hacker wohl die
heinrich-heine-universität im visier als
sie erfuhren dass sie stattdessen ein
krankenhaus lahmgelegt hatten so steht
es im bericht des nrw-justizministeriums
nahmen die täter von dem
erpressungsversuch abstand und händigten
einen schlüssel zur wiederherstellung
der betroffenen daten aus zu spät für
die 78 jährige zu spät für die klinik
die ihre patienten noch wochen nicht
wird normal behandeln können und für die
cyberkriminellen die wohl nur geld
erpressen wollten steht plötzlich ein
ganz anderer vorwurf im raum verdacht
auf fahrlässige tötung
die korona lage ist bei uns in
deutschland ist deutlich besser als in
vielen anderen ländern der welt und doch
sagt heute etwa der virologe christian
drosten
auch wir sind jetzt wieder im anstieg
heißt die lage verschlechtert sich das
robert koch institut meldet 2194 neue
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden das
ist der höchste wert seit april im
schnitt der vergangenen woche haben sich
laut johns hopkins universität 1490
menschen jeden tag neu angesteckt mir
dazu jetzt von susanne gelhard feiern
mit folgen für 600 besucher der
hamburger bar katze 100 von ihnen sucht
das gesundheitsamt nach einem corona
ausbruch noch immer das problem viele
hatten falsche kontaktdaten angegeben
virologen mahnen nun zuständiger
vorsicht und verschärfte maßnahmen wie
ihn früher zu verhindern
immer noch sehr stark auf die junge
bevölkerung beschränkt das war damals
nicht so und es wird geraume zeit dauern
noch mal wieder also mehrere wochen bis
sich das dann um verteilt auf ältere
bevölkerungsschichten wo dann auch
wieder noch mal wieder ein monat später
die krankenhausaufnahmen hoch gehen
werden
besonders in bayern wächst zurzeit die
zahl der neuinfektionen morgen beim
auftaktspiel der fußball bundesliga fc
bayern fc schalke 04 dürfen deshalb doch
keine zuschauer dabei sein die die
steigenden zahlen setzen sich aus
mehreren faktoren zusammen zu testen
wird deutlich mehr
zum anderen haben wir die
reiserückkehrer gehabt und letztendlich
durch nachlässigkeit in der bevölkerung
auch viel durch private feiern und so
dringlicher ist die entwicklung eines
impfstoffs mehrere deutsche hersteller
arbeiten mit hochdruck daran das mainzer
unternehmen bei montech will im oktober
die zulassung beantragen und bei
genehmigung in dieser neuen
produktionsstätte in marburg bis zu 750
millionen impfdosen pro jahr herstellen
ich gehe davon aus dass ab mitte 20 21
jeder in deutschland deren impfstoff
nehmen möchte auch an impfstoff bekommen
wer als erstes an der reihe ist
empfiehlt die ständige impfkommission
des robert koch instituts bei der frage
wer zuerst geimpft werden soll
richten wir uns zunächst danach wäre das
größte risiko für eine infektion hat und
wer von der in von der impfung besonders
profitieren könnte hierbei denken wir
zunächst an ältere chronisch kranke
patienten aber natürlich auch das
medizinische personal weiter hoffen also
auf einen corona impfstoff als
wichtigste hilfe im kampf gegen die
pandemie bewohner war auch wieder thema
beim neuen zdf-politbarometer und das
zeigt die maßnahmen von bund und ländern
stoßen immer noch auf große zustimmung
sehr viel umstrittener ist dagegen die
aufnahme weiterer flüchtlinge von den
griechischen inseln anton kuh chatten
hat details wer darf nach deutschland
kommen eine viel diskutierte frage nach
dem brand im flüchtlingslager maria aufl
s box deutschland will
teil der migranten aufnehmen und das ist
richtig so sagen 43 prozent der
befragten menschen in deutschland 46
prozent finden hingegen dass die
regierung das nur tun sollte wenn auch
andere eu-länder sich daran beteiligen
und 9 prozent sprechen sich gegen jede
aufnahme dieser flüchtlinge aus wenn
deutschland jetzt im alleingang einen
größeren teil der flüchtlinge aus maria
aufnimmt könnte das signalwirkung haben
fast zwei drittel der befragten dem
politbarometer erwarten dass sich dann
wieder mehr flüchtlinge auf den weg nach
europa machen
neben der flüchtlingsfrage ist die
korona pandemie das thema das die
deutschen noch immer am meisten
beschäftigt und da gibt es nach wie vor
großen rückhalt für abstand halten und
maske tragen
nur elf prozent der befragten finden die
aktuellen kroner maßnahmen übertrieben
angemessen und genau richtig sagen 69
prozent und 18 prozent wünschen sich
sogar härtere maßnahmen hinter den
protesten gegen geltende corona
maßnahmen steht nur eine kleine
minderheit
83 prozent der deutschen finden die
proteste nicht gut und von einer zweiten
corona welle geht auch eine große
mehrheit der deutschen aus das komplette
zdf-politbarometer gibt es heute abend
im heute-journal und auch jederzeit
online mit allen fragen und ergebnissen
zum durchklicken in unserer zdf heute
app auch die themen klimaschutz und
nachhaltigkeit bewegen viele und sind
heute top thema im bundestag
zur stunde werden weitere neuregelungen
aus dem klima paket der bundesregierung
beschlossen
thomas gonschior stellt die wichtigsten
vor welcher besteck trinkhalme aus
plastikteller aus styropor solche
wegwerfprodukte dürfen ab mitte
kommenden jahres nicht mehr verkauft
werden
ziel weniger müll mehr mehrweg produkte
deshalb soll außerdem gelten hersteller
und händler dürfen retouren
zurückgeschickten noch gute ware nicht
mehr vernichten sie müssen dafür sorgen
dass man diese produkte weiter
gebrauchen kann
das nennt sich obhutspflicht in die
pflicht nimmt sich übrigens der bund
selbst
seine behörden müssen umweltfreundliche
produkte bevorzugen weniger schadstoffe
erreichen soll das auch eine reform der
kfz steuer
heute abend die abstimmung über diese
pläne e autos bleiben von der steuer
befreit besonders umweltfreundliche
verbrenner werden entlastet steuern rauf
dagegen im kommenden jahr für neu
zugelassene spritfresser mit hohem co2
ausstoß die absicht käufer sollen weg
von konventionellen und hin zum
nachhaltigen auto neue erkenntnisse im
fall navalny nach angaben seines teams
ist der kreml-kritiker nachweislich
bereits in russland vergiftet worden und
zwar nicht durch einen tee am flughafen
sondern in einem hotel in der
sibirischen stadt tomsk system zeigte
auf instagram ein video aus dem
hotelzimmer ein deutsches labor soll das
gift in einer der mineralwasserflaschen
nachgewiesen haben hieß es
moskau hatte zuletzt gesagt aber in
dieser womöglich erst nach seiner
abreise nach deutschland vergiftet
worden als das corona virus im märz
italien als erstes in europa mit voller
wucht traf da fühlte sich das land
allein gelassen
die krankenhäuser hoffnungslos
überlastet schutzausrüstung fehlte in
den krematorien reihten sich die särge
auf und der rest europas auch
deutschland machte die grenzen dicht
zumindest am anfang
heute besuchte bundespräsident den
besonders schwer betroffenen norden
italiens seine botschaft solidarität
statt nationaler alleingänge annette
hilsenbeck
es ist ein bewegender moment
bundespräsident steinmeier trifft ärzte
aus bergamo und patienten die in der
korona krise zur behandlung nach
deutschland gebracht worden waren
wenn ich heute am leben bin dann dank
deutschland dass mir das leben gerettet
italiens staatspräsident hatte den hohen
gast aus deutschland zuvor in mailand
begrüßt dass sein erster auslandsbesuch
seit beginn der korona pandemie nach
italien geht kein zufall so der
bundespräsident er will ein zeichen
setzen
nach manchen missverständnissen die es
nicht nur zwischen italien und
deutschland gab weil sich gerade am
beginn der krise natürlich zunächst
einmal jede regierung auf die
notwendigkeiten innerhalb der eigenen
grenzen geschaut hat es ist deutlich
geworden wie sehr wir in europa
aufeinander angewiesen sind
italiens staatspräsident materieller
spricht nicht von der enttäuschung dies
zu beginn der korona krise in italien
gegeben hatte als deutschland
schutzmasken verweigerte sich mit
gemeinsamen schulden in eurobonds schwer
tat sondern lobt deutsche unterstützung
und die wiedergefundenen werte der eu
ein großes gefühl der solidarität und
einer gemeinsamen zukunft die gesichert
und entwickelt werden muss und ihm
diesen für die eu historischen moment
weil die position deutschlands
entscheidend dumm von mailand habe er
der korona toten gedacht so der
bundespräsident ein besuch im zeichen
der wieder erstarkten freundschaft der
beiden länder innerhalb europas in der
pandemie wurde in deutschland auch immer
die rolle der hausärzte betont als erste
anlaufstelle für verunsicherte patienten
und solche mit corona symptomen
da mussten die ärzte ganz schnell den
praxisalltag umorganisieren
zudem blieben viele die sonst regelmäßig
kamen aus angst vor ansteckung
monatelang weg wie es mittlerweile läuft
zeigt nicola albrecht
dem patienten trotz schutzscheibe weiter
seien alle gleich gut versorgen und
zusätzlich corona test durchführen
die pandemie fordert von hausarzt dr hut
und seinem team hier in frankfurt oder
nicht nur flexibilität sondern auch
kreativität für die korona abstriche
hatte deswegen die praxis um einen
behandlungsort erweitert das offene
fenster da vorne gibt es ein schild die
gehen hier rum um die praxis dann ist ja
ein mitarbeiter ein arzt und dann wird
das gleichzeitig hier also gemacht ohne
dass der patient oder der möglicherweise
infiziert in die praxis kommen muss
doktorhut praxis ist derzeit wieder voll
das war zu beginn der pandemie nicht so
rund 600 patienten blieben im zweiten
quartal weg obwohl in der region
ärztemangel herrscht auch stamm
patientin gundel der stadt eigentlich
notwendige termine verschoben
es war die unsicherheit welche patienten
dürfen überhaupt jetzt in die praxis
teilweise waren praxen auch geschlossen
in der übergangszeit und dann war es
einfach ja ich hab gesagt es geht auch
ohne quälst du dich mal durch
zwischenbilanz in der korona krise zieht
heute auch der deutsche hausärzteverband
die hauptkritik gilt der politik man
kämpfer an vorderster front ohne
strategischen die pandemie bekämpfung
eingebunden zu sein nichts gegen
biologen das sind hervorragende
wissenschaftler wir haben die kritik
dass tatsächlich wir als
hausärzteverband als hausärzte insgesamt
und zwar immer versucht haben aktiv
einzuschalten aber nicht ausreichend in
die entscheidung auch in die krisenstäbe
mit integriert worden sind die
grippeimpfung ist in dr hus praxis in
diesem herbst so gefragt wie nie
die neue herausforderung im falle der
erkrankung grippe oder corona denn die
symptome sind fast gleich das warten hat
ein ende die fußball bundesliga geht
wieder los norbert jetzt allerdings doch
ohne fans im stadion leider
genau morgen in bayern gegen schalke da
waren ja eigentlich 7500 zuschauer
eingeplant aber dann wurde in münchen
die kritische marke von 35 corona
infektion auf 100.000 einwohner
überschritten
sie liegt heute bei 47,6 ja und damit
darf kein publikum ins stadion schade
für die fans aber schön dass der ball
wieder rollt zum achten mal in serie
eröffnen die bayern als amtierender
meister hier in münchen die bundesliga
saison und starten damit gleichzeitig
mit der mission titelverteidigung
dann allerdings ohne thiago alcantara
der spanier wechselt für 30 millionen
euro zu jürgen klopp nach liverpool
ich kann da nur gratulieren er hat
bekommt einen topspieler aber auch einen
sensationell guten menschen schalke hat
seinen letzten 16 bundesliga spielen
nicht gewonnen und ist natürlich der
krasse außenseiter aber trotzdem freut
man sich in königsblau
schließlich geht es gegen den triple
sieger fc bayern als
saison-eröffnungsspiel also ganz ehrlich
viel cooler geht's ja eigentlich gar
nicht in der letzten saison verloren die
schalker in münchen übrigens mit 0 zu
fünft das von da nur die bayern kult
kein publikum im stadion abermillionen
vor dem bildschirm das spiel morgen
abend live bei uns im zdf zu sehen ab 20
uhr 15
nach über einem halben jahr zwangspause
hat sich jetzt auch der deutsche profi
handball auf der bildfläche
zurückgemeldet
die sg flensburg-handewitt gewann zum
auftakt der neuen
champions-league-saison in einem
dramatischen spiel gegen den polnischen
meister ks kielce knapp mit 31 30
der norweger magnus reed war mit sechs
treffern bester werfer beim deutschen
vizemeister und otto de france heute die
dritte und letzte alpen-etappe primus
roger slowenien bleibt spitzenreiter
gewonnen hat diese etappe aber ein
anderer oder eigentlich fast 2 arm in
arm in richtung ziellinie charts carabas
links und michal kwiatkowski rechts und
team in leos und einig waren sich die
beiden auch wer als erstes über die
ziellinie
dann durfte der pole quert kosten weil
nämlich der carabas schon das bergtrikot
so gut wie sicher hat hat er seinen
kollegen den etappensieg
das weihnachtsessen nicht weiter zu wenn
der maler und bildhauer gerhard richter
jetzt kommt auch ein feiner zug ein werk
schafft es millionen wert sein letztes
aber verschenkt er einfach diese drei
kirchenfenster schuf er für das älteste
kloster deutschlands die abtei sankt
mauritius in tholey im saarland
grundlage für die bunten formen und
muster war ein abstraktes bild dass
richter wiederholte und spiegelte der
88-jährige sagt dies soll sein letztes
großes werk seien mit der umsetzung sei
er sehr zufrieden und die benediktiner
mönche sind natürlich auch sehr
glücklich das wetter beschert uns morgen
strahlenden sonnenschein ob das auch
fürs wochenende gibt sagt ihm gleich und
hat ihr marietta slomka freut sich um
viertel vor zehn auf sie im heute
journal und wir freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder lust haben dabei zu sein
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und sagen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und liebe zuschauer ab morgen wird es
bei uns wieder etwas wärmer ein neues
hoch von der nordsee setzt sich jetzt in
mitteleuropa fest und es schneidet der
kaltluft den weg nach süden ab die muss
nämlich jetzt mehr und mehr nach osten
ausweichen ruhiges wetter bei uns ganz
anders hier am mittelmeer über
griechenland da haben wir einen
wirbelsturm der morgen früh die küste
erreicht wahrscheinlich mit orkanböen
und dann mit sintflutartigem regen regen
können wir auch gebraucht aber es bleibt
halt trocken ist wird er ja kalt in der
nacht in norddeutschland zwei bis sechs
grad bodenfrost zum beispiel in der
lüneburger heide ist möglich und morgen
haben dann dort temperaturen so von etwa
20 grad nur direkt am wasser ist es ein
bisschen kühler an den küsten und am
wärmsten wird es im südwesten am rhein
mit 23 bis 27 grad strahlender
sonnenschein kaum eine wolke am himmel
morgen aber der ostwind legt wieder zu
fallen dinge in der mitte und im süden
mit windstärke 4 bis 5 in
norddeutschland haben wir kaum wind aber
an der ostsee da weder dann frisch
allerdings aus westen und die aussichten
sonniges wetter über das wochenende
vielleicht mal am sonntag gewitter in
den alpen und temperaturen meist von 20
bis 28 grad ich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut